In this lesson, we covered a number
of ways to blend data together
using really different approaches.
We Unioned Multiple Data Sets
to create one longer data set,
we Joined different files together
that had a Field in Common
to create a data set containing
fields from both sources.
We used Fuzzy Matching to match together
two data sets with non-identical data.
And lastly, we used Spatial Matching
to blend two sources of data together
using spacial components like points and
regions.
As I mentioned in
the beginning of the lesson,
we rarely get the data
we need in one file.
So it's really useful to know how to
blend data together, from whatever
sources you have at your disposal,
to create your final analytic data set.